today is black friday and that means
that our black friday deal is back
that's right you can get 50 off a daily
wire membership
with code dw50 head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe or click the link in the
description below
take advantage of this offer while you
can 50
off your membership with code dw
50. you know this has been a very very
long
and trying year for a lot of people okay
and what's happening those democratic
governors
and mayors and dr fauci and all the
experts
are telling us we can't have our
holidays well we're not going to let
that stop
us okay in spite of all of the madness i
am going
to give you the patented highly
recommended
michael knowles cocktails for this
holiday season
the first drink up is a classic drink
the old fashioned you know i am not
exactly a hip kind of guy i'm pretty old
i'm not will wit okay
to begin you need a giant block of ice
if you have those big ice cube trays
really sets off the drink
now some people prefer to use bourbon
for the old fashioned i myself i've only
been a southern boy for two weeks so i'm
more of a rye guy
just you know you can eyeball it
yeah that's a nice that's a nice 20 24.
then you can toss in some bitters
and you're going to want a little peel
of orange
okay when you get the maple syrup some
people want a hundred percent vermont
pure expensive maple syrup yeah i don't
need that i think for 20 20
much more fitting to put in a little
angioma i'm not too good for angiomyma
unfortunately aunt jemima is one of the
casualties of 2020.
we can pour one out for her and to have
that drink after
you don't need to be shy about this you
pour a fair bit in there
nothing more old-fashioned than aunt
jemima who no longer exists
stir it up
[Music]
oh tastes so politically incorrect next
up
a little-known drink but it is one of my
favorites especially
when the weather gets a little bit
colder this is an old prohibition
cocktail called
the stinger the stinger again very
simple drink
it is cognac or brandy and
white creme de month it's a little
harder to find white creme de month but
it costs like two dollars when you find
it
so to begin with this we're gonna we're
gonna mix this one up you can either
have it on the rocks or
up we're gonna have it up obviously you
begin with a little bit of ice
then you pour in cognac again i don't i
don't measure you know you could
do two parts cognac one part creme de
month but really i'm just gonna eyeball
it
one mississippi two mississippi for the
creme de month
less is more when it comes to this
flavor if you've ever gone tailgating
and you know had gallons and gallons of
peppermint schnapps or something and
woken up feeling that your head was
about to explode
you know less is more when it comes to
the minty liqueurs
okay that's plenty i have very few
drinks actually shaken i prefer
i prefer to stir it unlike james bond
and then just
just on top for a little garnish a
little sprig of mint
[Music]
absolutely excellent ah tastes like
prohibition all over again which we are
in right now as a matter of fact
every time you take a sip you think oh
no is nussolini going to come to my door
is he going to bring his thugs shut down
my illegal happiness and festivities
no absolutely not because your bar is
not in the cellar of some closed down
tavern no
it's in your living room and you are
making the finest holiday drinks you can
despite the best effort of the left-wing
politicians
now before we get to the next ring don't
forget to check out our black friday
deal you can get 50
off a daily wire membership with code
dw50
this is a very serious discount guys and
the more of these i drink maybe the
discount will get even steeper i don't
know no this is
basically the best discount we've ever
run in our whole existence of our
company
we never do this and i cannot guarantee
that we will be able to do this again
next year
so if you've been on the fence about
getting a daily wire membership this
is your chance that is dailywire.com
subscribe
or click the link in the description to
get 50 off your membership
with code dw50 all right third drink up
this one maybe loosen your collar a
little bit folks maybe send the kids up
to their room
we are going to be making sex on the
beach now why would you have the sex on
the beach
during the holidays of 2020. it's
because my friends
i believe that the silver lining of
these awful lockdowns that we've had for
a year
is going to be the postcovid baby boom
so if you're going to have the postcovid
baby boom you might as well encourage it
with a drink that is enjoyed generally
speaking
by 20 something white women but maybe
could be enjoyed by all of us we will
take a little uh
trip so first you're going to get some
ice you don't need to waste your like
nice big ice cubes on this because
no one's no one's gonna care one shot
cranberry juice
one shot orange juice a shot of vodka
just a touch of peach schnapps again
less is more when it comes to the
schnapps
mix it up a little bit there nice little
fruity color
i put a little garnish here all right
well we'll go right in
and you have a few sips
tastes like the next generation of
americans
the final drink on this list i can't say
that i recommend it
this is a drink that i have not had
since college but it seems to me to be
the most 2020 of all 2020 drinks first
you begin with
a cheap plastic cup and then you add
a pure grain alcohol that would be the
drink make sure it's okay
yep still smells like poison uh pour it
in
yeah that's yeah seems about right it's
probably enough to kill an elephant
i have a little uh have a little 20 20
sip here
[Music]
tastes like poison too i can't feel my
tongue anymore
and for those of you who do not partake
of alcohol you will probably feel much
better tomorrow and all through 2021 i
think of sweet little alisa
who rarely ever indulges at all for
those of us who have taken the politics
a little bit harder this year
we are going to have a terrible terrible
hangover merry christmas
happy thanksgiving happy new year let's
look forward to 2021.